it's three outside
six to shoot attention before
25 seconds left in the fourth
so women
hi there its senior editor Kevin Van Ord
scanning in for reviewer Josiah rinaldin
to talk about NBA 2k15 NBA 2k15 has a
slick sense of movement actions like
faking right and floating the ball over
and nearby defender look sharp but going
through these motions feels even better
a great one-two punch beautiful pension
nasty Jam where players stuck
unrealistically close to one another in
past games 2k15 adds much more natural
spacing between bodies 2k sports took
significant technical strides with last
year's NBA release but it's the
reinvented movement system and improved
physics that make 2k15 such a success
handling the ball has never felt this
intuitive you can more easily change
direction during cuts and the finesse
moves delegated to the right analog
stick are now more reliable this
improved dexterity allows for craftier
deliberate offensive execution your
ability to create space opens up
mid-range jump shots and most players
are now equipped to post up and fade
away offense isn't easier it's smarter
you have to fake cut and step back to
earn this newfound space NBA 2k15
rewards players who can evaluate the
situation read the defense and move the
ball efficiently thousands of new
animations make the simplest of
movements more effective than they have
ever been back to grant six on the shot
clock on
engage to Jordan another throwing for a
baguette your position on the court your
players shooting prowess and how open
you are all factored into the new shot
meter that sits beneath the players feet
the better your situation the wider the
window for you to let loose a high
percentage shot the meter eliminates the
frustration that used to come along with
mastering each player's specific strokes
this time around you can much more
easily determine your release point from
the simple on-screen indicator the AI is
craftier so if you spend too much time
studying your man you generally miss
screens being set on either side this
isn't to say that every aspect has been
improved however offensive players are
often too slippery easily chewing
through your defense if you make a
simple mistake
losing your man as he goes for a layup
is common and this can be downright
frustrating when matching up against
players like LeBron James or Kevin
Durant this defensive shabby 'no siz
most apparent during the early portions
of the mic career mode here you
customize a character and enter the NBA
as nothing more than an unproven
prospect how you figure that genius
better to go undrafted and have a choice
then it be picked late by a stacked
playoff team where your chances of
making the team are about as high as my
chances of dating a supermodel which
despite my contagious charm are pretty
freakin slim instead of having you join
the draft the years career mode throws
you into the shoes of an undrafted
player on a ten day contract my park has
seen its fair share of improvements
including a reputation system that
unlocks upgrades as you expand your
reach and shorter games it's fully
featured but if you'd prefer to control
more than your single created player and
avoid getting stuck with ball hogs the
traditional online play option is still
there new to the series is my league
which is similar to the old Association
mode my league lets you design your own
personal basketball world that may last
for a single season or up to 80 years
the roster salary cap draft preferences
season length and dozens of other
settings are left up to you so really
this is your own personal
Fanbox my GM remains one of the most
imaginative offerings allowing you to
oversee any of the 30 teams as the
general manager you still monitor trades
and watch for available free agents but
new this year is a conversation system
that expands your day to day
responsibilities along with the
financial side of the business you need
to supervise player morale your media
presence and what your owner is hoping
to get out of his team but really where
NBA 2k15 truly shines is on the court
battling for space and effectively using
a screen to set up a wide open jumper is
superbly satisfying and the interaction
between all 10 men on the court at any
time has never looked or felt this real
a good defense shot share the ball
screens and
take on three-point line but you know
just got to be progressive get good
shots that make it right plays no turn
stem thank you so much Kevin it's not
easy in the NBA